une révolution depuis deux ans comme
tous ses collègues de l'atelier jean
louis béziat n'a plus de chef
une nouvelle organisation du travail qui
a bouleversé ses habitudes le chef
d'atelier qu'on avait à l'époque il faut
pas tous dirigés seront obligés de
passer par lui pour faire quoi que ce
soit comme maintenant au tour on est
indépendante par rapport à par rapport à
il ya dix ans en arrière
il se persuade centraliser l'ensemble et
là vous avez peut-être plus de petits
chefs va dire mais le travail sur mieux
mon bigoud emploie une soixantaine de
salariés la société engagée dans les
coloris fabrique et agences du mobilier
en bois massif démocratie participative
absence de hiérarchie mobiles ou des ce
que l'on appelle l'entreprise libérer la
croatie il ya quoi être deux en trois
mois voilà c'était pour savoir si ça va
continuer tous se réunissent une fois
par mois pour faire le point sur
l'activité et à la vie de l'entreprise
et à partir de ça pas de patron chez
nous donc c'est pas mené par un
responsable ou par
une figure d'autorité il ya différentes
personnes de l'entreprise qui prennent
la parole et qui donne des nouvelles
c'est extrêmement détendu et il ya une
parole à se libérer et donc ça en fait
des moments un peu privilégié de
communication entre les collègues
l'entreprise est organisé par cercle
hôtelier vente ou encore administratif à
la tête de chaque cercle en binôme
leader choisi par ses pairs mais qui
peut aussi changer
recruté il y à peine deux ans cet ancien
chef d'entreprise apprécient ce nouveau
mode de travail
l'objectif de l'entreprise libérer ces
de diluer l'ensemble des autorités qu'on
pourrait donner un patron à des chefs de
service ou à des chefs de diluer ces
autorités là pour les données en fait au
plus près du travail qui est réellement
réalisé dire plus on est proche de là où
on travaille plus on doit donner
l'autorité à son droit l'a affecté à
l'usinage isabelle cabral à 19 ans
d'atelier derrière elle
aujourd'hui elle travaille avec un
coordinateur et à gagner en autonomie
avec des axes de sortie et nous on
essaye de respecter le plus possible le
planning et après entre nous on décide
ou encore à y croyait beaucoup travaillé
pourquoi pas trop pour moi ça a changé
parce que tu peux prendre d'initiatives
à la tête de mobiles woods deux anciens
ingénieurs
le binôme géré aussi cinq autres
entreprises et 122 salariés à travers la
au sein de chacune
cette même façon de gouverner ça
n'empêche pas qu'il ait problème cela
n'empêche pas que des conflits sache pas
qui est qui et qui est des gens qui se
retrouvent pas qu'ils les gens qu'ils
soient partis voilà nous ont fait une
proposition
je pense que pour ceux qui sont raccord
avec notre raison d'être je crois qu'ici
je pense qu'il se retrouve alexis et son
associé ont repris mobile woods en 2006
et fait passer son chiffre d'affaires de
2 à 22 millions d'euros
basée à cravans près d'auxerre
l'entreprise voit chaque semaine des
candidatures afflué de toute la france